[Music]
so we're going to continue playing
mainline 184 with white
and quote-unquote boring chess with
black i'm going to try to expose people
to what boring chess looks like
because i think a lot of people need
some practice in in those types of
positions
okay so we're white the moon is the
enemy thank you now let's go e4
and let's see yeah we're gonna play the
danish
we're gonna play the danish and let's
see how a 1600 responds to the danish
gambit
okay and he accepts it so bishop c4
we are playing the danish and knight f6
so
black accepts the danish sort of a
semi-accepted danish
yeah i haven't i'm actually not familiar
with knight f6
so he takes the pawns kind of halfway
and of course c takes b2 bishop b2 is
the main line
now i assume that we should play knight
take c3 here there doesn't seem to be
too many other good moves
thank you 38 with a five damn girl
um yeah so e5 here can seem a little bit
tempting
does anybody see what nasty little
response black has planned
to the movie five and remember that when
your bishop is on c4 there is a drawback
to
the bishop's placement yeah so black has
the counter attacking move d5
opening up his pieces and
counter-attacking the bishop
so it's a better idea to just take on c3
i'm pretty sure
and now e5 is more of a threat than it
was on the previous move
so what's the point behind this entire
operation we have a lead in development
and we need to act very very fast if we
let black castle and consolidate we're
simply going to be upon down
so we got to step on the gas pedal and
so
now the time has come for what move
for e5 the time has come for e5 if we
don't play this move now he's going to
castle on the next move
and we also oh i just noticed we had a
better move i noticed we had a tactic we
had bishop f7 potentially although no
maybe e5 is good
no maybe e5 is good okay goes d5 so
you can see that at this level players
are familiar with basic ideas
and you know that's why you don't want
to play these gimmicky
and i'm not calling the danish a
gimmicky opening but truly gimmicky
openings you don't want to play
because they're not going to work
anymore all right so what should we do
how do we how do we untangle our pieces
what do we do
well the first thing we need to
understand is well this move queen a4
check may seem like it wins the bishop
but it doesn't
because of knight c6 knight c6 is the
typical response to that and the bishop
is defended
now when we're trying to calculate these
types of positions you want to start
with the simplest
move if if you determine that the
simplest move leads to a good position
then you save yourself time and you
minimize the risk of a mistake so the
simplest move here is he takes f6 taking
the knight
so if we take the knight he takes the
bishop what's the simplest move in that
position
well we can take his queen king takes
queen and in that final position
what do we do and taking on passant just
because it's on pasan is
not a good idea he just takes back and
he's a pawn up we play f takes g7 and
look at that pawn on g7
how can we defend that pawn if necessary
what follow-up move will we be able to
play if he goes rook g8 for example
bishop h6 bingo
that pawn is a huge asset in the end
game because his rook is going to be
tied down
his king is going to be weak and it's
going to be on d8 so we're going to be
able to castle long with check i don't
know if any of this is making sense but
all of these things are indicating to me
that the end game is at the very least
not worse for white
and practically speaking probably a very
good idea
so we take his knight he's going to take
our bishop he could also take his take
our knight first but
that doesn't change much wow he takes
now that's a very strange move i think
his idea
is that he thinks that bishop takes c3
is going to win back
uh the the piece because after bc queen
takes c3 that's a fork
against our king and rook but what
detail has he missed
in what move should we play here should
we take on d5 with the queen should we
take with the bishop should we not take
it all
should we give a check on b5 okay so
bishop d2 would blunder the bishop our
bishop is still hanging
oh yeah that's people answering the
question yeah
so we can safely take on d5
because after bishop c3 bc queen c3
that's a fork
but we defend against the fork with
bishop d2 and we're totally fine
and i'll i'll talk about some of the
other moves in this position after the
game
he's lost he's simply a piece down
yeah i was hoping he would take on c4
that would allow me to demonstrate the
end game
okay i assume he's going to take the
knight
[Music]
yeah there's just not much to to talk
about here he can also try to castle no
he takes
so there's one detail that i didn't
mention after bishop d2
if you notice this bishop it will become
undefended after bishop d2 because it
will
block the connection between the queen
and the bishop thank you 704 so it may
seem like he has a fork
queen e5 check but of course as many are
indicating
the follow-up move queen e2 is crucial
he hasn't castled yet
queen e2 pins his king to his queen
forces the queen trade and wins the game
i imagine that that's going to happen i
think he's relying on queen e5
and perhaps he'll spot it at this point
but that's a very nice idea always yeah
when you fight queen e2 he can't take
the rook because
he's pinned to the king that's just
calculation i mean honestly there's no
other way to find this than just to
calculate and
notice these things
all right yeah this is resigned here
exactly you resign here
bishop b3 is playable for sure but if
you can trade queens when you're up a
piece
then you know you should do it
just be better exactly
now but that is something you can always
notice is that when the e-file is open
you should always consider the
possibility of a check on e2
or if you're black a check on e7 like
you should always be aware that
that kind of stuff can impact the line
okay so knight d7 so
we should first understand that his
queen is not going anywhere until he
moves this king away from the e file
we can trade on our own terms so taking
on e5 this is
me splitting hairs because it doesn't
matter we're up a piece anyway
but if you want it to be super accurate
you could understand that
that allows his knight to be centralized
the concept of trading on your own terms
comes very it comes in very handy here
so we can make a move that forces him to
take our queen
allowing us to centralize our king
that's good because it's an end game
and we can use the fact that his queen
is pinned in order to develop our pieces
and there's a couple of ways to i love
the move bishop c3
but i also want to develop all of our
pieces so it seems a little bit simpler
to me to go knight f3
we don't know where this bishop will be
long maybe we'll go bishop f4 later
knight f3 just seems a little bit more
natural to me bishop c3 is also fine
it honestly does not matter
it just doesn't
okay well it's
it's going to be an end game after he
trades queens somewhere between a
queenless middle game and an end game
now he has to take
so to the question of whether it is
risky to centralize the king
if both rocks are on the board look at
this position from a concrete standpoint
first of all this rook on a8
is nowhere near even being developed
he's going to have to bring the bishop
out
and then if you imagine a scenario where
he gives you a check on e8
when our king is on e2 is that scary
thank you walfenty
is that a scary possibility well not
really because we can just block the
check with bishop e3
the second thing we can do is we can
still castle by hand
so after he takes our queen we can go
rook h to e1
and then drop our king on f1 which is
where it's very safe
and then our rock is going to be
controlling e8
okay let's see what he does i don't
really know what he's thinking about he
can
i assume go queen to e7 but that doesn't
strike me as very dangerous
yeah this guy does need mr if queenie
simon we're just going to take and then
castle
we are just going to take and castle and
win
the nine development is worth it because
when you have the queens traded it's
much less important to castle as a
as a rule than when the queens are on
the board because the chance of you
getting attacked in the center
is greatly diminished and also you want
your king to be in the center in most
end games
so it's not such a bad idea
yeah okay so he does go queen e7 all
right let's take it
that move took a while now i have a very
interesting question
we can castle short or we can castle
long which way should we castle
and why this is a good this is a good
uh example of sort of concrete thinking
we should castle long now i know some
people are looking at this but
and saying well isn't the king very weak
on the queen side we don't have our bnc
pawns anymore
but remember the queens are off the
board he doesn't have any of his pieces
out our king is in
zero danger and the great thing about
castling long is our rook is
automatically activated so it's far more
efficient to castle long in this case
than go rookie one we might just
checkmate him here in fact it's very
likely that we will
knight f6 so most people would play rook
he one check but we have a move that is
even better we can start with a
different move
and make sure this king doesn't have
access to the f8 square we can play
bishop b4 first
not playing immediately is like is his
key here just
surveying all the options now after king
e8 then we give a check on e1 and it's
far more efficient
castling long centralizes the rook and
it keeps the king closer to the center
which is good because it's an
end game okay king d8 oh he's
really asking for it here what is the
best discovered check
so it's not made remember that he can
block
any check with his bishop so the best
option here is simply to win as much
material as possible the easiest is just
to take on b7
and take his rook even if there was some
marginally better option
go for the practical continuation win
his rook and then you know you're gonna
win the game
it's over okay now we can throw another
check in
before we take his rook i mean
and actually we if we want to play
efficiently we don't even have to take
his rook
we have check made in like five moves
so instead of taking his rook what else
do we have it's made in one
two three four made in four moves
check now this is not made he can still
block with his knight
and is it a good idea to take the knight
there it is because his bishop is pinned
and the king will not be able to
recapture because the rook defends the
bishop
king moves aside right into the other
discovery and then we take his bishop
with three pieces up
and his king moves into the discover
check again and then what's the mating
move we have one two
three four mating moves and somebody
give me one of them
he resigns what would be the mating move
here the nicest is bishop ca
also we could play bishop f5 if anywhere
on this diagonal is made the rook
control the row gives the check
the other row cuts the king off one way
the bishop cuts it off
the other way and uh that's about it
but don't go here because the king can
block uh can hide under the bishop's
shadow
all right so let's have a look
that was a pretty easy game once he
wanted his piece um
but nonetheless so
obviously the the accepted danish is is
c takes me to and i'm i'm i'm currently
analyzing this
for a course on refuting gambit so i
can't
guarantee that i know the best line for
black yet
but the traditional main line the way to
equalize with black although this isn't
the best move but i can get an
advantage here if he plays very
accurately
but the move d5 is traditionally
considered to be the safest option
which sacrifices back one of the pawns
in order to accelerate the speed of
black's development
the point here is that white takes with
the bishop you don't want to take with a
pawn because now the bishop looks stupid
after bishop takes d5 you've opened the
diagonal for the bishop and you've put
this bishop on a very awkward square
so the move knight f6 kind of comes with
tempo it doesn't technically threaten
the bishop
but you don't want to give this bishop
away it's white's main attacker
if you haven't seen this line before
this may look like a blunder however
why does knight f6 look like a blunder
artel thank you because bishop takes f7
is a classic tactic
separating the king and the queen but if
you do know this line
or if you have acute tactical vision
you'll notice that black can take the
bishop
after queen takes d it's always
important to check for this
and the king on e1 is exposed whoops is
exposed to a discovered check of black
zone
so it may appear that black one's a
piece white has to move the king and
then black takes the queen but
that doesn't tell the whole story what
can i do here
yeah bishop c5 is a phenomenal line
now when you're faced with the discovery
of this sort remember that you can
sometimes
use the piece that is already lost block
the check within and at least get
something in return so queen d2
wins the bishop back and you get this
end game which is considered to be equal
black has sacrificed two of his pawns
back
and there's opposite colored bishops
which gives the position kind of a
drawish tendency but
i've struggled here with black nepo
played this a couple of times against me
and so i this is not my favorite line
although it is equal from a technical
standpoint both sides have a big pawn
majority on their respective flanks
so if you want a reliable line that
gives equality
against the danish this is it but
currently i'm analyzing other moves in
this position trying to get an advantage
for black
okay so that is one option but he played
knight f6
knight takes c3 and bishop b4 so one of
the things that i didn't notice
uh and should have noticed is the fact
that this bishop is undefended
so in italy in the italian this occurs
as well we have a tactic here bishop
takes f7 check that was also possible
and after king f7 of course we go queen
b3 winning back to bishop
this isn't my favor i mean i don't think
this is that amazing because black can
go d5
after queen takes before he can develop
the knight with tempo so even though
black's king is currently exposed
black blackened castle by hand going
rookie in king g8 so i like black's
position here
so i think e5 is still the best move a
lot of people
will will now think but couldn't you
play queen b3 first
and you have to understand that changing
the order of a line
often completely changes the nature of
of the line
and gives your opponent other defensive
resources so here for example
black could have what move that defends
against bishop f7 well black can just
take
and then black and castle and black is
totally out of the woods your white is
in trouble
or pawn down this is hanging the queen
is misplaced because the knight will
take with tempo so
this move is not effective for example
because of knight takes e4
or queen e7 is also possible yeah
queenie's 7 is possible as well
but here you can take on f7 anyway so
perhaps that is not as accurate
still this is fine for black after
knight c6 so anyways
that was possible we played e5 and he
responds with d5
now this is a move queen e7 that a lot
of people are worried about but you
shouldn't be
because it's generally very easy to
defend against this move how can white
cover up the pin while renewing the
thread of e takes f6 and this is the
reason why queen e7 is often bad
after queen e2 the knight is once again
hanging
and if you say okay now i'll play d5 and
give up the pawn or something
well this no longer works because after
ef6 white wins a piece you attack the
queen
and then you can take with the very same
bishop that was on c4
and if black tries d4 how can white
save the knight this is a very important
concept to understand
this rarely ends up winning a piece
because you can play a3
and i see a lot of you are familiar with
this followed by b4 attacking the bishop
so at a maximum black can win the pawn
back but that's
very little release okay
so d5 ef6 and he lost the game here with
queen takes f6
but after d takes c4 we take the queen
we go f takes g7 and i think white is
better here
so he's got two moves he can give a
check on e8 and go rg8
if he gives a check on e8 we can block
with a knight and then we can deliver a
check on g5 and castle
white or black can get mated here very
easily even though it's the end game
and the fact that black's not well
developed on the queen side
is biting him in the you-know-what so i
think black is in pretty big trouble
here
of course bishop g4 can be easily met
with f3
blocking the pin and if he goes rogue g8
we have a choice we can give a check on
g5 and again we can castle
or we can go bishop h6 to defend the
pawn and then still castle
so black is in pretty big trouble in the
end game
um i hope that makes sense we're not
analyzing this very deeply but
there isn't much to analyze here it's
pretty clear that black is
facing a very serious initiative
and after after he takes with the queen
we play bishop d5
and the game is basically over now
a couple of you suggested like a check
on e2 this would be very
counterproductive
because because the queen would no
longer have the possibility of defending
the rook
and so black could go for example even
king f8 would be a very good move
after bishop d5 bishop c3 again when the
queen is on d1 you can play bishop d2
connecting the queen in the rook here
you can't do that so you end up losing
the rook
okay so it's important to just take on
d5
now how do you see this how do you know
to start with this move
again the rule and the one of the
takeaways from this game is to start
if you have a position where there's a
lot of options start with the simplest
move that may be the capture that may be
the forcing move
there's this famous tip you know to look
at checks captures and threats
and that's true in a tactical position
when you're trying to find checkmate for
example
but in these positions where there's
clearly no mate you're just trying to
find the best move
the simplest move can be a lot of
different things it can be the capture
it can be the check
so here for example it's very clear that
the simplest move is just to take on d5
start with the simplest move because
that can save you a lot of
effort because if this move works then
it's very clear that
that's the one you should go for i don't
know if that makes sense
thank you the apprentice gifting to sin
onion
that's right here something all right
so bishop d5 bishop c3 and the rest is
is history
i mean knight f3 is a nice move it takes
and castles and the game is over any
questions
about the rest of the game or about the
beginning of the game you saw that mate
seeing the king has no squares well yeah
that's
just pattern recognition i mean it's not
too difficult to see that the king is no
squares here you just have to understand
what your pieces are doing and what the
what they're controlling
like i see instinctively that the bishop
is controlling f8 the rook is
controlling the d file
that doesn't happen consciously i've
seen so many of these patterns that it
all happens in an instant
is there any way for black to keep the
queens on the board yeah i mean black
should not have given
the check on e5 if i was playing black
here and i was trying to swindle my
opponent
yeah but the problem is if you go queen
f6 now the check on e2 is pretty strong
although no although bishop b6 and black
is okay so i would play queen f6 they're
trying to keep the queens on the board
and then you know knight f3 castles
castles
black is completely lost there's no
compensation for the piece but keeping
the queens on the board keeps a little
bit more chances alive
um could the queen have trapped the
bishop after you take the pawn
not sure what you're referring to but
this is what happened queen e2 is the
key
the key resource that pins the queens
um let me see
can you go over bishop takes b7 after
the queen takes a one line
um oh you mean in case of queen e2 check
so check here here here here here
well bishop b7 doesn't do anything
because just take back thank you dave b
for the sub
and if you go bishop a3 check going for
the checkmate on e8 well you can't do
that because of the pen thank you the
apprentice